[Applause]
[Applause]
welcome good to see you congratulations
yes you are the best two french versions
of the country here's the bad news from
now on it's a competition there can only
be one winner yes
the french table from serbian surrey and
bouchon bistro from hexam northumberland
are our top two french contenders here's
how i found them
i've loved french food for many years
so i couldn't wait to start searching
for the creme de la creme of french
restaurants
[Music]
my team traveled all over britain to
visit the places you nominated where you
love to eat
[Music]
from stroud to cambridge from teddington
to tunbridge wales from norwich to
battersea presentation wise it's very
basic
as a native frenchman the f-word maitre
d can certainly spot exceptional french
cuisine
it's not pretentious it's fairly small
it's friendly you get well look after
it's modern french
so they're not stuck
at their own backside
after months of whittling daniel
nominations we finally found two
outstanding restaurants
tucked away in serberton 13 miles from
london is the gastronomic treat the
french table
[Music]
runs his kitchen with french passion
a good plate it's like a beautiful woman
he needs to look good he needs to taste
good and you mustn't be disappointed
because that's it you don't love it
anymore eric puts his heart and soul
into the cooking and his wife sarah
brings charm to the front of house
people think that french cuisine is just
you know heavy sauces and snails and
frogs legs and it's much much more thank
you
classic combination that husband and
wife team lady at the front hard-ass
chef french behind that's great
first up for me rietz of mackerel
is that how it's normally served like
that that's how they serve food at the
ritz
i know it's good because i like it
and you know i brought my sensitive and
love in it so i know it's good
for the main course i just had to try
the house special pyrenean lamb
god it's like butter
incredible i wouldn't expect to find
a lamb of that quality
on a menu
tucked away the backer beyond serbato in
a bistro
the lamb delicious
[Music]
what a fine
for me the hard thing
is that there's only two restaurants
that are going through to cooking the
f-word restaurant and this
having been in love with french food for
many years has been a very very tough
choice
and with only two restaurants going
through
the french table was one of them
congratulations
brilliant can't believe it really can't
believe it and just think quite excited
i'm very excited
[Music]
they have just raised the bar it's gonna
be [ __ ] hard to beat them i tell you
that's one of the best dishes i've eaten
all year oh thank you yeah but i mean
really nice
the french table in serbiton is through
[Music]
and i found an amazing restaurant to
take them on
bouchon bistro is in rural
northumberland in a small town called
hexam it's a local favorite
and i knew just the man to check it out
is that great hi thanks how are you
john baptiste
grew up in restaurants
and his uncle ran one of the most
amazing restaurants in lyon so if
there's one person that can spot an
amazing bistro it's definitely john
baptiste
run by greg bureau the bouchon has only
been open for two years but his
reputation is spreading as the most
genuine french restaurant for miles
around
people here are uh well traveled they
visited france many many times and it
feels like they are in france when they
come to buchanan
is the head chef he first fell in love
with cooking as a boy growing up in
brittany cooking with a
shellfish and fish really reminds me of
when i was younger and when i first
started to cook that's when i really
discovered what we could do with fish
and everything brings lots of memories
really
for you
salad pizza
lovely thank you i wish you a bit thank
you
very tasty very fresh
the products are beautifully cooked
you can ask for better than that
the reason i have to cook is simply
because you get a whole fish some raw
vegetables and from all that you can
create something that is really magical
pretty much
the veal perfectly cooked so tender you
can really see that um
the garlic and the stove nose nose is
cooking
nico is obviously a very talented
individual but running a successful
kitchen relies on teamwork and his
geordie colleagues are very loyal
is your team uh are they all french or
no none of them are none of them are no
so you're only a froggy in there yes i'm
the one yeah we need to have a good
relationship i'll teach him how to reply
and jody he can teach me i would reply
in french it's all good at the end of
the day it's going to be a new language
beforehand
jb said bouchon bistro was faultlessly
brilliant and in this category i was
prepared to trust his instinct 100
hi it's gordon ramsay how are you i'm
very good thank you very much the french
category have been huge i bet
there can only be two restaurants that
go through to the f word dining room
right so
the bouchon bistro
it's one of those restaurants
congratulations wow you're through
goodness me
well done
fantastic bravo
mercier
garden
[Music]
it's just it's just amazing absolutely
amazing it's just
can't believe it's nice spinning up
what does it mean we made it
[Music]
so i've found my top two french
restaurants
well the f word diners prefer the
bouchon bistro simple charm
or the french table's elegant fine
dining
who'll be crowned the airport's best
local french restaurant we're about to
find out
this needs to be the best service of
your lives now don't let your
restaurants down and more importantly
the f-word diners yeah they're here for
a phenomenal experience make it count
yes let's go cooking bon chance on your
section
we're back in london at the f word
restaurant
tonight we're going french from nearly
200 nominations we found the f word's
best two local french restaurants
bistro in northumberland and the french
table in serberton
they'll both be serving 25 portions of
their own starters if the f-word diners
don't like it they don't pay and that
includes family and friendship
[Music]
so they're underway and every single
plate they send out is crucial
i've challenged them to cook one of my
favorite ingredients foie gras
a french classic that is the ultimate
test for these restaurants
while they prepare their own recipes
here's how i do it
foie gras has to be the chef's ultimate
ingredient rich sumptuous melt in your
mouth and absolutely delicious first off
caramelise your apples core
peel
slice
hot pan
butter
just starting to foam
apples in
season
sugar
caramelized
calvados
thumb over the end
[Applause]
removed from heat tarragon chop
foie gras
peat knife
slice
salt
pepper
hot pan no oil no butter
[Applause]
fry
remove
rest
[Applause]
slice
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a camel from the apples
[Music]
[Applause]
salt
program with caramelised apples
done
gentlemen remember this is not a race i
want those dishes looking yes perfect
yeah we're sure
both restaurants are cooking their own
recipe it's a fascinating battle between
fine dining and rustic bistro cooking
but who will come out on top
[Music]
bouchon bistro in hexam near newcastle
serves no frills classic french food
basically it's simple rustic and
flavorful
bouchon bistro are pan frying their foie
gras and serving it with spinach and
paneer peas this is a sweet french bread
that they bake in their own restaurant
that will complement the richness of the
foie gras
good now nico what was that you put on
there it looks like a biscuit what is
that it's a funny piece
it's a bit like a gingerbread yeah
gingerbread
they look fantastic happy with those
very happy yeah and why is the
gingerbread on top and underneath to
absorb the fat why is that
just to keep the the crease for the
gingerbread so it doesn't go soggy on
the spinach as well great yeah lovely
all right all right on you guys so what
you put underneath there what is that
that's a toasted toasted with the
walnuts
yeah and where did you buy that from we
make it you made it good i like that uh
they look beautiful are you happy with
those yes yes gorgeous good
the french table in serbiton serves fine
dining french food in a relaxed
environment
when you're in a vegetable this is
france you have to show your passport
where you come in
they are serving their foie gras on top
of a walnut brioche with a figure musket
grape chutney and pickled walnuts the
chutney is seasoned with minionette
pepper a blend of peppercorns used in
french cooking now eric at the weekend
you do cooking classes for your
customers yes we do what kind of things
you teach them well we teach them um
there's one saturday morning where we do
a bread classes bread classes yeah yeah
how do you teach them to make good bread
it's a special secret garden
yeah you need to feel like it's titties
you know when they come back in your
hands so you need the bread it needs to
feel like titties you know what they're
doing
okay right okay nikki well done thank
you yeah well done excellent hey guys
those first two tables look fantastic
keep them all like that
i'll be surprised yep if anyone refuses
to pay for that prague
here's my french food in the envy of the
world
i'm going back to my beloved paris to
find out about one of the most famous
french foods of all the croissants
as we brits embrace coffee shop culture
the croissant is fast becoming our
favorite breakfast and last year we ate
a staggering 60 million of them
[Music]
but the majority were mass produced by
machines in factories and they can often
contain additives for taste color and to
make them last longer
sadly the majority of questions we get
in this country tastes like old
cardboard so i'm off to paris to learn
the art of a perfect croissant
[Music]
we may expect inferior question in the
uk but even in paris the factory
croissant is beginning to take over
[Music]
many french boulangeries are now buying
in the same mass-produced dough and if
you want to find a traditional authentic
handmade croissant you've got to look a
little harder
[Music]
as a young chef i spent a couple of
years working my ass off in paris i was
very fortunate to live above the most
amazing boulangerie eating questions
seven days a week what i never got
chance to do was perfect the perfect
question so i'm going back to the floor
to see if i can turn out a batch of
questions as a pro baker
arno del montel has been hand making
croissants for over 20 years
[Music]
he's a president who's still producing
the delicious rare handmade versions
we're all missing out on
what's the secret behind your croissants
um
love
butter yeah good ingredients yes and can
you teach the perfect question or is it
all in the field
it depends of the student right
i hope i don't disappoint him
okay so whose recipe is this did you
steal it from an english chef um
not really
the ingredients to make the dough are
simple flour sugar milk salt and yeast
but they're perfectly balanced and the
smallest mistake will ruin the entire
batch
with water and eggs added
the dough is then chilled and rested to
use for the next day's baking okay it's
24 hours so you're that far in advance
every time you're always in advance yes
using yesterday's pastry the dough is
gently rolled before we add the key
ingredient
okay and that's the butter that's the
batter so it's like a whole slab
of butter in the middle voila the french
love rich foods
and almost a third of every mouth of
anno's croissants will be butter the
best butter you can find on the market
which is rare today because a lot of
questions are made with margarine and
cheap forms of fat
to produce the all-important layers in a
croissant
the dough has to be rolled then folded
rolled then folded three times
to create over 70 layers of dough and
butter in each croissant
the pastry is cut into triangles and
rolled into the famous croissant shape
but you need to be gentle so as not to
crush the layers it's the technique the
friendship perfected and do it like this
but you're addressing it it's like
you're cressing uh
wait it's true
to caress me
right caress
but don't crush it
every morning he has the challenge of
hand rolling 400 croissants for
discerning prisiens can i match his
lightning speed
so there's 40 croissants here yeah
normally how long would that take to
make no around three minutes three
minutes
okay
three two one
to match arno i needed to be able to
roll one every four and a half seconds
two guys
don't crush this [ __ ]
i'm held up
15 seconds left thanks
[Music]
i thought coming back to paris wouldn't
be like it was like 20 years ago when i
was getting my ass kicked
the royal croissant are then gently
heated to activate the yeast so they
rise
they're glazed with egg and then they're
baked
[Music]
right seem 20 minutes and come out
crispy golden and delicious
the smell was taking me back 20 years
smell is amazing i couldn't wait to
taste if all our hard work was worth it
oh my god
inside perfect
slight moist
crisp on the outside and that bit there
you see all the the layers right here
25 years of
experience inside
yeah
and and some love oh my god
that is amazing honestly and thank you
for giving me a proper insight
to a bit of french history
it's my pleasure and my passion
delicious handmade croissants are a
world away from factory versions but i
want to put this to the test
i'm back at the garden or to conduct an
unscientific but very revealing test on
some francophiles well they prefer a
handmade quest on by me or are they
going to be conned by something
processed
that's the first one we've been in two
questions for a week you've been eating
questions all week that's great news
which one out of both questions you
prefer no the flakier one for this one
it's got more taste
oh my god this is whitewash first one
was drier first one was dry
moist and
creamier creamier it's interesting
the first one or the second one second
the second one now in terms of flavor do
you prefer the first one or the second
one
now which one you prefer the first one
the second one second one second sir
second one
why
the layer is more layered
that one tastes like a proper one you
might get from a decent restaurant now
which one you prefer the first one or
the second one
second second why tasty tasty she's spot
on i'm so glad the public prefer the
handmade buttery croissant everyone
should be asking their baker if there's
a handmade
croissants from a factory in france
[Music]
nikki how long have been the head chef
at the bouchon uh about a year and a
couple of months and uh what's craig
like as a young sous chef does he learn
quickly he does he's really he's a good
crafter he loves his job he's really
fast where are you from craig where
about i'm from newcastle newcastle yeah
so you're a supporter of newcastle yes
we won't until they disappeared at the
premier league thanks for that chef yes
damn and nick your last table yeah well
done yes yeah yeah two killers
let's go you know we're going yes go
please
the flying rod to be honest wasn't the
most overwhelming of the taste
the biscuits are very strong and stays
in the mouth and they're
not too
tasty to be honest
paula my darling welcome how are you
sweet i'm fine thank you good to see you
i welcome to edward how do you think
craig your son is doing this evening
oh i think he's he's doing amazing yeah
yeah he's a very determined focused
young man what would it mean for him
tonight to win oh i mean everything
absolutely everything it just would mean
the world yeah you must be very proud
and watching them cook like that
now um why newcastle
uh why newcastle i was sent i was sent
to newcastle by my bus in france so
first impressions when you went up there
cold cold but the the jordy girls are
very very warm
what was the french type of smaller like
it was good i mean i really appreciated
the dish uh maybe a little bit soggy at
the bottom obviously the fact of the
foia being on top of the brioche would
you steal that dish and put it on the
dushon's menu
more importantly are you going to pay
for the fogger we are paying for it you
are playing absolutely what a gentleman
a foreigner are you gonna pay for it
no why not it just it was the texture
the texture yeah just in terms of
undercooked overcooked
undercooked
[Laughter]
very well balanced it's a lovely texture
of the soft frog with the crunches of
the bread and walnuts texture was really
really nice um dressing was delicious
and grapes were
they tasted really fresh and crunchy and
full of flavor how are we moving i'm a
little bit nervous i am
and then i actually feel really calm
because he looks really calm and
controlled where does that passion come
from because he is incredibly passionate
about food his grandmother from the
loire valley um always used to cook for
ten children that she had and i think
from seeing that from a very early age
he just took it on what do you think of
beautifully cooked melty in the mouth i
have to say i think it wasn't seasoned
enough i think that let it down the most
important question are you going to pay
for it um i said no you said no no
[Music]
chance fargo um panic piece it's like a
gingerbread on top
fargo
very pink in the middle that
sauce finished with apricot and some
proper spinach
flavor delicious for me needs a bit more
color on the outside a little bit more
salt slightly bland french table
presentation lovely a really nice color
on the foie gras fuego is more cooked
inside
really good
foie gras
nice and crisp on the outside cooked
perfectly
bouchon just a little bit too pink
but what did the diners think the
results are in
how well do you think you did out of 25
i don't know i'd say
14 15. pessimistic how old do you think
you did out of 25 um eric 26 26.
you had one ah
excellent okay
first of all before i announce the
results uh congratulations yeah to you
both yeah i thought you did bloody well
thank you gordon thank you thank you
so uh
yeah you go first yeah the number of
customers out of 25 that are happy to
pay for their foie gras
is it's 15 out of 25.
really good thank you
uh
10 customers
not wishing to pay and feedback slightly
too oily slightly too oily and a bit
undercooked a bit undercooked right
french table yes the number of customers
out of 25 are willing to pay for your
foie gras
is
20 out of 25 well done really well
really well done
really well done
actually only five customers that aren't
paying feedback
a little bit too bland in terms of
seasoning yeah both of you well done
yeah thank you you're only five
behind this can change you're now gonna
be cooking 50 portions of your lamb and
50 portions of your grey mullet yeah
make it absolutely exceptional you can
pull this back easily clear down get
ready for the main course well done
welcome back to the f1 right now both
residents are going to cook their main
courses first up bush on bistro
are you ready
[Music]
bistro signature dish is fried grain
mullet with pre lentils
first nico dices a carrot and onion
[Music]
add pre lentils a bokeh garni some veal
stock and simmers for the shellfish
bisque he flies off longisin heads and
shells
flambes with cognac
and that's shellfish stock
cooking with a shellfish and fish really
reminds me of
my time in britain he strains the mix
adds cream and butter
and leaves to reduce
nico fillets the mullet scores the skin
and fries leaving it pink in the middle
the quarters set mushrooms and fries in
butter we get the steps from a guy
called well we call him andy mushroom we
don't know his name really
lentils
mushrooms
mullet
shellfish sauce
one uh creme leds on table two
bouchons gray mullet with pre-lentils
and steps
served
[Music]
when you cook great mullet would you
cook it like salmon and serve it a
little bit pink inside or cook all the
way through lightly pink slightly pink a
little bit of moisture
because the english is somewhat
squeamish a little bit with sort of
slightly pink yes yeah yes almost
translucent to get there often
not often but yeah every now and then
the fish comes back and they ask it in a
restaurant you'll be more cooked through
yeah yeah
i love that longer sauce yeah it needs
that kind of luxuriousness with lentils
yeah yes huh very good service plate and
danny's absolutely
eric you have an english wife yes yes
what's wrong with french ladies
they're too cookie
they're too cocky
oh too snobby snobby oh too posh i used
to have a french girlfriend yeah harry
perry yeah fourth place please
here's what the french table of cooking
for main course
[Music]
come on guys one for one lamb
the french table sings the dish this
pyreneen rack of lamb with aubergine
tempura
eric first prepares the spatulae a
different take on pasta popular in el
sass
he whisks with water eggs and creme
fraiche
and pipes the spatula into boiling water
to blanch
very cold water stop the cooking
straight away to make his puree eric
scores an aubergine adding oil salt
nutmeg
herbs the provence and vagues
he blends the bait flesh with a knob of
butter
we sell loads of portion every night
eric seals his lamb and adds garlic and
rosemary
for the gremolata i chopped herb sauce
he mixes garlic parsley not too thin i
don't like when it's too thin you lose
too much flavor with lemon juice and
olive oil
tiny pinch of salt and that's it he deep
fries aubergine in tempura batter
then eric fry she rolls a chop chalot
and his spatula with butter
[Music]
and adds white wine and cream
aubergine puree
giroles
tempura
lamb it's just pink beautiful
it's not nice to ask for wildlife in a
restaurant
peyronie in rack of lamb with tempura
aubergine served
[Music]
it looks fantastic i love the smell the
fragrance are you using rosemary in
there or time what is that no it was
mine you little bit of rosemary a bit of
parmesan just instead of the salt yep
that's a seasoning so the french have
got a
reputation
for being arrogant would you call
yourself an arrogant frenchman no i'm
becoming more english um a little bit
more english as you getting older you're
getting more mellow exactly yeah now the
scores are incredibly close so far
there's only five yeah points in front
of you so you can pull this back yeah
keep it going yes there we are really
good make sure all that seasoning is
exactly the same way yes
aubergine nice and crisp grandma allowed
to finish on top
craig lentils tasted yeah not just the
first pot everything yes we chef
eric last table yeah make them as good
as your first table yes let's go please
let's go
yeah eric really well done yeah
for me i think the mullet was my uh was
my preferred course the flavors in it
complemented a lot better i love the
fish the sauce on the fish particularly
was lovely it was really subtle now good
to see you again
talking about the green lights when i
saw the presentation i thought the
colors looked a bit bland and and it
looked quite flat it didn't look it
didn't look good
yes
it was absolutely beautiful it melted in
the mouth every texture complemented the
next so it's absolute pleasure to eat i
thought my lamb was really really well
cooked i like it really rare so the rest
of the table thought it was undercooked
i absolutely loved it it was really
moist and tender how was the lamb for me
the lamb it was too salty pretty and
just start looking chewy big question
are you going to pay for it
my goodness me you're a one tough cookie
aren't you huh
bouchon bistro grey mullet now
not the most widely renowned fish
however
lentils
seps and a really nice longer sinju
that's delicious
because he's managed to enhance the
flavor of the grey mullet with that
amazing light longusting bisque sauce
i hardly ever use cream on it but the
flavor of that is delicious more
importantly highly sustainable and the
seps
go brilliantly well with it really good
right french table's lamb um beautifully
cooked
nice and pink aubergine puree is quite
interesting
giron mushrooms and a very light
fragrant lamb stock
there's a lot of things going on that
plate however the balance is absolutely
perfect my one slight concern is all
this raw fat here two really seriously
unique dishes however i think the grey
mullet just has the edge
right um first of all before with the
results uh well done um seriously well
done yes thank you okay jp
thank you demolar this time around i'll
switch around we'll start with the
french table the number of customers
that happy to pay for your rack of lambs
out of 50
is
36 out of 50. well done
that's good
14 didn't pay why not
um stacking undercooked and um yeah lack
of flavors yeah but listen i mean i find
it hard to believe there's lots of
flavors in there for me i thought the
balance worked brilliantly fred you
don't look very happy what's the matter
because i always expect you a bit more
yeah do you want to go and kill a
customer no no
i'm trying to understand because we give
all our love and the passion in to that
dish
we'll be disappointed but at the time
we've got the delivery
okay bhushan bistro
the number of customers happy to pay
for your grey mullet out of 50 is
it's 40 out of 50 well done
[Applause]
[Music]
to convince the diners to pay for gay
monet
is bloody good news well done
bistro so far you have 55 out of 75
french table
you have 56 out of 75 that's amazing
well done great job
[Applause]
okay
it all comes down to dessert
stay down get ready for your crepes sure
well done good job
right this week janet finds out which
came first the chicken or the egg
i've asked janet street porter to
provide rare mangalits of picks and
miniature dexter cattle
to ensure we have the best possible meat
for the final of our best local
restaurant competition but i think she's
still got room for one more breed
i've chosen rare eggs worth poultry
because they're good egg layers and
great to eat
but before she can begin she needs to
answer the age-old question
how do chickens have sex there's a man
in yorkshire called chris who knows the
answer
and chris has got just the cocky cockle
for the job he's gone without it now for
about two weeks all right girls you're
ready sex god is coming
[Music]
look at it
hot to trot he's having a look
what's that is that
is that saying i'm ready that's it yep
that's saying come and get me yeah could
i ask you really something stupid do
chickens have willies no they're all
internalized okay we've got a little no
nothing nothing bubbly bit nothing well
is bum's quivering i don't know if that
means he's aroused
oh no hang on we're getting somewhere
[Music]
that's it that's it janet
what's in it for her
nothing
i think he's getting the taste now we
probably will probably straight onto
another one though
he pushes her on the ground yeah her
tail lifts up yeah and he's literally
just sperm is just dropping out of him
onto her she then stores it in a sack
within herself and that's that sperm
that she uses for the next two to three
weeks you'll actually see by the end of
today's back end will be covered it'll
be dripping you'll see it's
dripping with what sperm oh no
no too much information
isn't it yeah
it's been a week since janet sat in on
some hot chicken sex action and now
she's taking delivery of a batch of
fertilized eggs ready to hatch within 24
hours
i'll get on with it
the first of janet's chicks begin to
hatch but it's stuck in its shell acting
on advice she performs an emergency
exerion i've got to give this one a
little bit of a helping hand he's got
stuck
i'm taking a bit of the shell off to
give him a bit of help
all right all right
i've got to put it out of his misery i
can't stand that tweeting
there's a leg
i have a leg out
oh
stop knocking about
[Music]
what's it
the mother and child
new chicks need to spend around three
weeks gaining strength and weight under
a broody lamp before they can go free
range so janet books her new arrival in
with a neighboring farm for some heat
treatment
you look a bit healthier
i'll tell you what you're just like
peter mandelson the ultimate survivor
i'm gonna call you mandy
23 chicks from another batch have
hatched and join mandy under the lamp
with the birds settled and soaking up
some rays all janet can do is leave them
to grow under the care of a neighbor
jack
when janet returns to check on her
chicks she's amazed at their progress
god they're huge
where's my mandy
where's the one i hatched
um
well she she never grew actually
came in one morning she was just dead
dead as a daniel and the family
the thing is i've never given birth
mandy
i brought mandy into the world
i'm pretty pissed off man he couldn't
shape up forgive me
there's nothing more to say
please forgive me so this is what we're
left with
but these have grown so much i can't
wait to see how big they are in four
weeks time
yeah no they're certainly growing by
then
janet's got a healthy batch of chicks
exworth mature rapidly for the table so
our diners in the final can look forward
to some fantastic chicken in the f-word
restaurant
right welcome back to the f-word now
it's time for dessert
[Music]
crepes susettes basically pancakes a
real old-school classic first off you
make the batter 125 grams of flour
salt
2 eggs
beet make it well in the flour
combine
slowly add 300 ml of milk
add melted butter
whisk
orange zest
set aside to rest
sauce
oranges
peel and segment
keep juice
heat 50 grams of sugar
that caramel really nice and dark
ground onion
add the orange juice
remove from heat
coat oranges
crepes butter
flip and cook the other side
fold into quarters
this smells amazing spoon over orange
sauce
crepe susette
done
let's go every crate perfect yes
oh let's go watch your face
fred no one's got no [ __ ] hair left
nico you've got five pants at work at
the same time eric you've only got full
gun at the same time
is that the difference between brittany
and paris brittany are the experts on
the pancakes the french table were
beaten in the main course by bouchon
bistro they're clearly feeling the
pressure and they seem less confident
now
maybe because they're just one point in
the lead it's neck and neck
for the french table winning could
catapult this exciting suburban
restaurant into the london super league
just to win there's no there's no
english word for that
there's no english word so i'll have to
find a french one it'd be fantastic for
bouchon bistro success tonight could
really put this rural northern
restaurant on the culinary map if pusha
were to win it would be just amazing i
think it will really boost our
confidence
the pressure is on
you just burn your eyebrows
don't go crazy with the sauce guys there
you go crazy the sauce you're gonna
flood the pancake and make it soggy yeah
yeah yeah they look delicious well done
service please nico is a great tosser
pancake it's your fault yours with a
palette knife why are you opting out not
tossing your pancake i'm
concentrated it's an important toss yeah
you're going to flip it we're going to
use a spatula i think you've got the
balls to flip it oh sure go on
well done well done well done well done
big newcastle bollocks
this is fascinating because they're
pretty much neck and neck however i
think nico's got the edge because he's
calm his collective and those pancakes
are absolutely delicious eric all of a
sudden has sunk into one slightly
disappeared all that swagger's gone and
it's less arrogant and more focused
this is neck and neck yeah right those
crepes are sat there saw it's coming or
yeah yeah
okay now you don't serve as much sauce
as nikki why is that you just want a
less yeah i think a bit too soggy
otherwise
i like my pancakes not too soy you know
i get nervous when you're this quiet why
have you clammed up why have you gone
into one are you sulking it's a bit
cheeky it's a bit thick well let it down
though yeah
do you need some more milk yes
i told you to say something i i i feel
like i'm cooking with a completely
different chef so you guys started main
course confident yeah now all of a
sudden you've gone into one what's the
matter nothing so come on keep it going
come on come on come on i thought you
would rise to the pressure
not sink
go
excellent delicious looking crepes and
uh yeah job well done
it was absolutely delicious really nice
and moist and went really well with the
tang of the orange and just it was
fantastic
do you have a bit of a sweet tooth
yeah yes yeah
how are the
fantastic yeah crepes
did you like most about them it was they
were just so light and the sauce was
absolutely fantastic it wasn't too
bitter it wasn't too sweet
and the big question are you going to be
paying for your painting i am you are
yeah good i'm glad to hear
you've actually closed your restaurants
to be here tonight absolutely yes if you
don't win
will you regret closing the restaurant
not at all no it's been a fantastic
experience we loved it
no regrets whatsoever our customers are
supporting us all the way fingers
crossed can we take this one yes uh more
importantly whatever happens at the end
of this result um you should be
incredibly proud of your team and you
should be incredibly proud of yourself
yeah definitely thank you thank you
if we win
you'll be able to hear her from
newcastle i'm not kidding you she'll be
like an atomic bomb going off
i thought my dessert was uh was okay to
be honest i i like the crepes were well
cooked um they had good flavor but it
lacked a bit of sauce and the fruit
could have done with a bit more and i
thought the flavor wasn't as strong as
it could have been i love the crap
absolutely just really soft crispy on
the outside as well it's just perfect
not overcooked not stodgy light fluffy
went down really nice dessert yes um it
was a little bit too thick for the
plants yeah and i didn't think there was
enough sauce and not enough i was
waiting for a bit more of a punch they
were cooked by your husband i'm sure
they were damn yeah so it's really
nerve-wracking now are you going to pay
for them no i don't you're not paying
for your husband's credit no not today
that's very fair-minded yeah and how's
it going to be in the back of the taxi
on the way home tonight not very good
one of the first one yeah i think so
one in the spare room
so the results are in and it's time to
find out exactly who will be crowned the
f word's best local french restaurant
good luck to you both yes jb okay french
table gonna go first with you yes
and for your dessert out of 25 you got
[Music]
9 out of 25.
that is a big kick in the bollocks uh
why
okay the the main reason is the crepe
was too thick lack of sauce as one not
enough sauce on the plates you adjusted
the thickness halfway through
did you know they were going out that
thick
it was thick of our wanted yes but not
fake no and they were that thick
that your wife didn't pay for them
okay bouchon
if you get 10 out of 25e dessert you tie
and then i'll decide who wins
if you get more than 10
then you are the f word's best local
french restaurant
cool
okay out of 25 customers the amount
they're happy to pay
for your crepe suzette
is
[Music]
it's 17. well done
two fantastic courses
[Music]
really really really good
okay bouchon congratulations you're now
third on the leaderboard i hope to see
you in the semi-final congratulations
i can't speak honest to god i'm just so
proud
really really proud to win this is just
phenomenal i really can't believe it
it's just amazing it's
great it's
you know
the biggest moment of my life
so bouchon bistro have made it onto the
leaderboard in third position but with
six weeks to go will they hold on to
their place in the semi-final